[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's wednesday what they
used to call hump day
you think you've had a stressful week
imagine being kamala harris
you take your first big trip south of
the border to what we used to call the
developing world and you're pretty
excited about it because you know
that as a licensed person of color all
the other people of color you're gonna
meet will be thrilled to see you
that's how it works in the people of
color community
they've got so much in common that
getting along is effortless it's one big
happy community
you're oppressed they're oppressed
you'll be friends if you're kamala
harris that's what you've always assumed
but it turns out you were wrong you
finally get to guatemala and you
discover that actually the people there
detest you they could care less about
all the glass ceilings you say you've
shattered they're not impressed by your
political science degree
or the fact that you once chaired the
black law students association in
college
they find you phony and annoying in fact
they strongly prefer the orange man you
replaced
at least he was funny so they tell you
to buzz off and go home get out of here
don't come back imagine how that must
feel if you're kamala harris quite the
psychic blow
so you can't really blame the unnamed
white house staffer who swooped in to
save the day
hiring a fake univision reporter to suck
up to camel harris and make her feel
better
we can't prove that happened though it
does make sense we do know that
univision denies that the lady who told
harris
i voted for you at a press conference
had ever worked for the network
so whoever she was she made kamala
harris's day
thank you harris replied gratefully and
then her spirits raised
kamala harris returned to immigration
policy what is her immigration policy
exactly
simple now that we've solved every
domestic problem and turned this country
into a peaceful happy utopia
it's time to take all the money we've
got left over and give it to central
america
only by doing that can we solve the
quote root causes of immigration
watch what we must do
to address the root causes of migration
to address the root causes the issue of
root causes
is not going to be solved in one trip to
address the root causes as though it's
something that can be dealt with
overnight
to feel the effects of those root causes
on our shores
and the root causes are based on the
problems and the challenges
that people are facing in countries like
guatemala which is why i was there
we have to address the root causes
there's a lot of root causes so what are
these root causes well they include
climate change of course violence
against women
uber shortages in midtown over holiday
weekends and the patriarchy
once we solve those we're done we've
solved the problem
so it's simple make latin america
perfect that's all we need to do it
shouldn't be hard
people like kamala harris have a
demonstrated record of dramatically
improving everything they touch
take a trip on bay area rapid transit
sometime and you'll see what we mean
which is not to say that transforming
honduras into monaco will be
effortless a project like that could
take weeks
but no matter how long it takes we have
a moral responsibility to do it
because as sandy cortez learned during
her recent undergraduate days at boston
university
we're the ones who made central america
crappy in the first place
it's our fault everything is our fault
and especially this
what we as a country what the united
states
has not done is actually own up to the
fact
that we have contributed to regime
change
destabilization and interventionist
foreign policy
that has contributed to these awful
conditions
throughout latin america and it
we cannot as a country no matter who it
is
continue to show up in latin america and
say
that this is their fault or that
they are to blame
now wait a second sandy recognizing that
you were an international studies major
but still
some of us are wondering wasn't it spain
that brutally colonized latin america
so shouldn't madrid be kicking into the
reconstruction fund here or is european
spain now considered a nation of color
and therefore blameless we'll have to
check with the bu professor on that and
get back to you
but in the meantime here's an idea kind
of a random one why don't we fix the
united states first
we had a conversation with of all people
the president of el salvador not so long
ago and he made that point
we are in his country shooting a
documentary on ms-13
and immigration during that interview
the president pointed out that actually
it might make more sense for people on
say the south side of chicago
to apply for refugee status in el
salvador not the other way around
because
it's less dangerous than el salvador the
united states has seen a
dramatic increase in crime and in
murders
yes in cities across the country what
would your advice be
to leaders in the us to be tough and
crime
actually now before el salvador was the
murder capital of the world
like three three years ago we were the
murder captain of the world
now crime has been reduced by 75 percent
violent crimes and so now it is more
dangerous
to live in chicago for example than to
live in los angeles
we'll show you more from that it's on
our originals episode on fox nation it's
about how el salvador
tamed ms-13 but the president's point
what you just saw
is not crazy it's not just a talking
point it's actually true
according to the numbers el salvador is
in fact safer than many major american
cities el salvador
safer than baltimore for example in 2018
baltimore had 51 murders per hundred
thousand people the same year san
salvador
had a smaller number fifty per hundred
thousand since elvenar was long the most
dangerous con
city in the hemisphere baltimore by the
way also has a higher murder rate than
guatemala
honduras and afghanistan so
why don't people who live in baltimore
have a right to apply for asylum in
central america
thanks to good leadership el salvador is
getting safer
meanwhile thanks to people like kamala
harris our country is becoming far more
dangerous
from vicious attacks in broad daylight
to cold
blooded murders by night another summer
of sin is
already underway in new york city
shootings here to date are up 81 percent
this weekend alone 27 people were
wounded in 22 shootings
including a manhattan federal prosecutor
hit by a stray bullet in the face
while having dinner at a restaurant
bullets went flying in new jersey this
weekend where a birthday party turned
into a mass shooting
14 partygoers were shot two died
community members blame
gang wars chicago had a worse weekend
where
nine people were killed and 38 injured
by gunfire
the victims include a 15-year-old boy
shot in the head
while sitting on a front porch
so it really is getting more dangerous
it's not your imagination and by the way
murder may be the only event in human
life that the us government tracks
accurately it's kind of hard to hide the
body most of the time so we know for a
fact
that major american cities saw a massive
increase in homicides overall 33 percent
increase in homicides last year and
that's continuing this year
and that leads some people to wonder why
kamala harris is promising to rebuild
central america rather than
america one of the people wondering is a
man called andrew holmes
my message goes out to the president
goes out to everybody mary and everybody
come get on the grounds do what we got
to do
we need them to come out on the streets
here you know you fly
that air force one over there to take
care of people overseas and don't take
care of the united states don't take
care of chicago
and the same thing with all elected
officials come on out here on these
streets
these streets are full of blood well
yeah
that's not a partisan talking point it's
true
how can they continue to ignore what's
happening in chicago and not just in
chicago
a lot of places the formerly peaceful
city of knoxville for example tennessee
knoxville is now on track for its
deadliest year in history even worse
than last year which is at the previous
record
so what happened to knoxville well the
same thing that
always happens to places that decline
terrible leadership
neoliberal nonsense frenzies of
guilt-fuelled professional class
self-hatred
elected morons like india can canon
india concannon is somehow the mayor of
knoxville
she recently announced that she would
personally join in painting a blm mural
quote
i understand now more than ever it is
not okay just to stand up to justice
inequity she told reporters
we must all be actively anti-racist
anti-racist so what are the practical
consequences of so-called anti-racism
well we know we sit all around us the
consequences are more misery
and more race hatred no question about
that ask your kids what they're learning
in school
behind the scenes this ideology means
fewer and less effective police crime
spikes drug addicts living in the park
children murdered in drive-bys
that's all still happening across the
country in fact it's happening more but
getting less coverage
you rarely hear the phrase defund the
police these days
why because normal people of all colors
of all political registrations normal
people found that slogan terrifying and
deranged because it is
so democrats told their troops to pick a
new euphemism but the idea
didn't disappear it's still with us
here's congresswoman corey bush of st
louis explaining that police are the
real threat to public safety
i understand that people don't like the
slogan i get that but i don't like death
i don't like black death i don't like to
keep seeing my people die at the hands
of police
and nothing is happening i don't like
that so i think i can't care about
people's feelings i can't care about
you know what if you like what i'm
saying or not my people are dying and
that's what i have to look
at my people
what does talk like that bring us in the
end nowhere good
but in point of fact everything she said
is untrue a lot of people are dying
in saint louis but not at the hands of
police what's happening there
well the murder rate in st louis has
literally skyrocketed you're now more
likely to be shot to death in st
louis than you are to be killed in
guatemala city guatemala city
a place that has been famous for decades
for being violent
but st louis is now more violent that's
true so maybe it's our country that
needs the attention these days
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else